hey what's up everyone pretty sure got
here because of search and you're
looking at the genetics Cube from the
new movie Dungeons and Dragons
um honor Amongst Thieves and we got this
one a dragon a black dragon recall from
the movie as well okay let's go and look
at recall first very cool stuff let's
put the gelatinous cube here on one side
you can skip ahead if you're looking for
that but we'll start off with recall
himself box here looks pretty
straightforward here rayco is name any
instructions here okay you can see an
ancient black dragon who once roamed the
zombie evermos record is a vicious
Fighter the ability to spew deadly acid
on this Force okay you want to say DND
will know that black dragons always have
a corrosive effect instead of fire
breath because not all dragons we fly
fire he opens up his wingspan he's about
30 cm tall wingspan measures 20 inches
each or about 50 cmy okay
movement on mouse let's check out what's
in this box keep it straight forward
this is the first time I'm unboxing this
you guys are going to be experiencing it
together with me
okay here we go let's get this uh
the tape off
for more tape here this way
here again from his box prison okay here
we go oh you get some assembly require
it
so from this box here we got it and he
comes on like that
put the Box away
we've got an instruction manual here
adult assembly required punch this in
and okay the wings do not do fold away
in some ways and then his drawer also
opens we're going to use this and
display it we love our toys to be opened
up and journal after all you can see the
entire whole display at the back there
saw this off
to sit plastic free but they did not say
frustration free two very boring minutes
later 2
000 years later no we feed the dragon
from its prison very nice hot plastic
hey there's another box here maybe
there's even more accessories oh no guys
we've been beat it there's nothing in
the box there's something preventing the
wings from being uh pressed against the
Box itself so there's nothing inside
thought it was a box but let's get
record
okay this is recall here
there's a bit of articulation here on
his hip
you can pause him limited I would say
but I think this would be the default
there he is let's get his wings in the
wings itself can
is has a bit of joints and resistance to
it you can hear me click
and we can just insert the socket oh
goes in very nicely this one I've
adjusted it nicely
we plug it in that's pretty much it
we've got to get his tail in
and it can open up all the way back
to simulate a more flying position or if
you can tilt it up like that
he is coming in for the soup
yeah
so his mouth opens up
locks in nicely and there's a bit of
tension here
I'm bringing up close here can you can
you adjust his horns no I can't so
that's how recall looks like let's put
on his tail
this is the way in
uh
come on yeah boy
got him in
there you go good balance till does not
really uh move around apart from this
part I think
very limited motion
and there we have it recall which is hit
could actually adjust a bit more but
what you see is what you get is our
black dragon spews acid or corrosive
bowel I've not watched the movie yet one
of the major antagonists in the movie
hopefully so okay let's give you another
look around from the rear
straightforward toy as we sit
um the wingspan's about 30 cm and he is
about 30 cm tall as well so if you are
really looking for a nice dragon
possibly to even use in your campaigns
this might be an option okay let's get
him out of the way I think this is one
of the most straightforward toys that we
have let's go and look at the gelatinous
cube okay before we get into the
gelatinous cute proper let's talk about
today's sponsor secret lab here geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of format
function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co okay thanks Ecolab for
sponsoring this video let's go check out
what's in here
um Jonathan is cute we can actually see
Chris Pine over here and it comes with
14 accessories as well I wonder if it
actually fits the figures that is
available a transparent gelatinous Cube
that dissolves any prey
use mostly has like a janitor for
dungeons compatible 6 inch figures
compatible 6 inch figures and this thing
is well they call it a cute because it
was the cube measurements wise not quite
a cute 19.8 CM by 18.8 CM this looks
like more of a very good display piece
rather than a Toyota itself I'm actually
looking looking forward to this more
of course it's definitely more cool
okay that's it for the Box itself
because Springs character is there let's
get this Halloween
this comes from the golden archive
generation is cute it does not have much
instruction same thing
let's look at the base insert it in and
put in the stand oh wow there's some
small little section here and you can
put in all the different accessories
let's see how it looks like from here
you can make him stand up as well
interesting
oh straight up we get these ready and
the accessories are right in here
looks like a barbarian X
coins gold coins set of gold coins I'm
pretty sure that a normal figurine will
be able to use these these accessories
very good for flavor
this looks like the stand internally
uh healing potion oh this is grimoire
this looks nice it's a hard plastic nice
because it's all perspective they're not
going to give you the whole bottle
itself get this up
hmm they're pauldrons pauldrons are
shield you can see what it looks like
here
a skeleton leg the head itself uh scroll
this looks like a scroll of sorts and
hey another X
part of a shield
something's missing here oh okay
looks like pouch
is it in the bag of holding
and in the last one
oh
a bow
possibly someone's head bone I want to
put it like this
according to instructions
okay it's very soft plastic in general
so you just Peg it in
okay then you put in this next bit
because there are two packs here at the
top
they require you to slide it in nicely
carefully slide it in ensuring that the
packs up here or it comes up quickly
and then we'll push it down
hooray it does look like it bends quite
a bit but we know this is a gelatinous
cube after all so once you have this
able you're recommended to put your
figure in like this
okay
and it's like reaching for the shield
itself
together let's put this all together
first
before we put in the figure and see how
it looks like with and without the
figure
they recommend that you actually seal it
up by putting in another the other
section here
I like it that it's very the joints are
very sturdy and tight
that way everything looks good
okay so the cube looks like
oh it's a very nice 3d effect that is
popping out from the cube itself give
you guys a look what it looks like all
around
and then
the top part is to put in a
Bolt
and it just closes like a lid
ideally
yep
it's a small little section here which
because it's like bent
cool okay
here's the lid all nice and dandy
not much to see from the bottom
think of this like a a cool way to
actually display your your action
figures itself
okay and if you want to open up okay
it's pretty straightforward so right now
we're going to put an action figure in
and what do we have
is Tom Hiddleston
I think he is a figurine that looks
pretty we don't increase mine so we have
to settle for Tom Hiddleston
and we'll put him in
so that he looks like he's reaching into
the space itself
okay
you guys can see this
oh that's pretty straightforward
and we put his hand here
you can articulate him so that he is
like floating proper instead of that
okay are you guys ready for the review
ho ho not too bad
what do you guys think compared to let's
see the one that we see in the Box
there's this button here that shows him
putting his hand out so what does this
mean if we didn't have this part here oh
we could show that his hand is trying to
reach out from here
oh not too bad
and if you angled it slightly higher you
could get him looking like
Chris Pine itself let's let's put him
let's put his legs in like this
and put his hand through
okay his head looks weird
okay not too bad actually
not very opaque in some ways it's very
hard to make out natural figure but you
get the idea I think people get the idea
of what this is let me put this maybe
put this accessory threaded in here
and then we cover the box is there like
a specific way that you need to cover
the case itself oh yes there is so there
is a specific arrangement of how you can
actually close the case the lid
snaps pretty nicely together if you look
at that
okay that's how it looks like with a
figure inside and he's like reaching
reaching inside to reaching out to
escape but if a cube has gotten you this
far in yeah definitely pretty much have
gone already you know slowly consume you
for the next
well hopefully not in eternity
the cues are if I'm not wrong resistance
against electricity
and you better be able to get out this
or don't even get in this way
pretty nice see all the accessories here
Scrolls skeleton and certainly I don't
think you're able to complete a full
complete skeleton but there we have it
this is the gelatinous cube from
Dungeons and Dragons Hasbro has sent it
over to us thank you so much in
conjunction with their new movie
as well
so let us know in the comment section
below will you actually be getting this
I think the gelatinous cube well simple
just mix and looks great for a display
piece especially if you are into this
starting it is obviously a square or a
blob
for its most part
but you can't deny the flavor behind it
I think DND fans will really love this
okay that's it I'm Gerald here from gig
culture really appreciate you hanging
out with me and checking out this box
let me know if there's any questions in
the comment section below and remember
to follow us on all our socials over
here and I'll see you in the next one I
would imagine that in a situation you'll
see Tommy Anderson running away from a
gelatinous cube
this thing was really slow guys I'm not
sure how if he is in normal uh healthy
mode he will actually be eaten or
consumed by one but possibly this could
a reenactment of him running away and
then bam men's in there right now oh